la sixième journée d'action contre la
réforme des retraites s'annonce massives
demain train avion école éboueur ou
encore routier perturbations aussi sur
les routes illustration allez tiens en
banlieue de Lille ou des routiers ont
procédé des ce matin à débarrasses
filtrants
on est gentil aujourd'hui on distribue
des tracts on filtre etc les actions
futures sont certainement plus fortes
demain possiblement nous faisons entrer
le mois de mars dans notre histoire de
France le mois de novembre de 2018 est
entré dans notre histoire le moi de
décembre 95 est entré dans notre
histoire le mois de mai 68 est entré
dans notre histoire et ben est-ce que la
question se pose aujourd'hui vous savez
c'est un livre qui a une page blanche
maintenant c'est aux gens qui m'écoutent
c'est eux qui vont les créer ou qui vont
pas l'écrire
ok j'ai 57 ans c'est bon je vais être
ça fait un petit moment que je milite
des sondages de ce type j'en ai jamais
vu qu'on est 63 % qui soutiennent
l'appel au blocage des syndicats
monsieur 59 % qui soutiennent la grève
reconductible dans les transports
visiblement eux ils sont pas choqués par
les déclarations c'est à vous de faire
fructifier aussi
parce que ce que fait la CGT aujourd'hui
c'est une forme d'appropriation mais
vous trouvez que c'est une forme de
privatisation des moyens de production
de la communauté nationale cette
inacceptable et la réquisition bien sûr
que je l'appelle un moment donné je vais
vous dire il faut bloquer les bloqueurs
peut-être que dans deux semaines dans
trois semaines quand les gens quand ils
ne pourront plus se déplacer peut-être
que vous les ouvrir on verra bien alors
là mais vivre cette espérée le but
partout c'est de désorganiser au maximum
la production et si la question c'est de
savoir si on veut mettre à genoux
l'économie française la réponse elle est
oui et il y a un certain nombre
d'expressions mettre l'économie à genoux
par exemple qui ne sont pas entendable
parce que mettre l'économie à genoux
c'est en réalité mettre les travailleurs
à genoux c'est mettre ceux qui ont
besoin d'un emploi je ne sais mettre
ceux qui déjà rencontré des difficultés
dans des difficultés encore plus grandes
ce signe de moustache n'est pas est
quand même un signe fort est un signe de
pouvoir est un signe de combat ça le
durcit ça le vieillit même d'ailleurs ça
montre que l'homme se doit de porter
cette organisation syndicale qui est la
CGT de cette façon je vais leur dire
messieurs mesdames les importants les
très grands dirigeants et vous autres
comprenez bien pourquoi il vous tape
comme ça du matin au soir on vous
traitant de voyou pour un rien de
feignant etc pourquoi parce qu'ils
peuvent rien contre le peuple qui
travaille parce qu'il y a rien qui
marche sans le travail humain rien
absolument rien on appelle aussi des
salariés on appelle des commerçants on
sait que ce sera le cas dans certains
endroits les commerçants abcdo des
salariés à mettre dans leur bureau stop
64 ans le logo commun de toute l'Inter
syndicale on peut faire plus fort que le
31 janvier dernier Laurent Berger nous
son côté n'a pas vraiment de surnom
connu
c'est Laurent c'est même pas Lolo c'est
Laurent
ces heures-ci tout le monde se demande
et lui vous a dit vous bloquez tout ce
que vous pouvez et moi je vous dis
pareil bloquer tout ce que vous pouvez
le député LFI Louis Boyard s'est fait
remarquer ce week-end en lançant à
concours sur Tik Tok en direction des
jeunes parce que cette réforme nous
concerne nous aussi les jeunes on
s'attend à ce que tous les lycées et
toutes les universités soient bloquées
contre la réforme des retraites c'est
pourquoi on lance le hashtag blocus
challenge postez vos plus belles photos
de blocus de lycée et d'université parmi
ces photos on en tirera une sorte et
l'équipe de bloqueurs sera invité à
visiter l'Assemblée nationale avec nous
du coup on s'est demandé comment est-ce
qu'on pouvait faire pour que les jeunes
puissent être visibles dans cette
mobilisation et aussi pour les informer
qu'il allait y avoir cette mobilisation
donc bah on s'est dit on va faire ce
qu'on sait faire parce que enfin moi je
suis un jeune qui utilise TikTok souvent
donc on utilise des codes qui sont les
nôtres puis on s'est dit aussi que ça
les déclencher une panique bourgeoise
qui allait en faire parler quand vous
avez un député de la France insoumise
monsieur Boyard qui appelle à faire des
selfies du meilleur blocage en vue de
les inviter à l'Assemblée je leur
explique et je leur dis attention ce que
vous êtes en train de faire là sais pas
vous qui allez responsable politique
c'est les Français dans leur quotidien
c'est dangereux de faire ça alors ce que
fait avec son concours de selfie je
trouve que c'est pas respecté nos
institutions et donc c'est pas se
respecter en tant que lu rentrez chez
vous camarades arrêtez tout vous trompez
cette réforme et cette réforme de gauche
oui oui vous avez bien entendu réforme
de gauche regardez c'est le ministre du
Travail Olivier du soft lui-même qui
vous le dit en une du Parisien c'est
très réforme de gauche et oui c'est la
droite qui va la beauté la
substantiellement d'ailleurs modifié le
texte on fera de cette réforme une vraie
réforme d'ailleurs de droite et cette
réforme est tellement de gauche qu'à la
droite de la droite on s'en
revendiquement je la voterai parce que
d'abord c'est ma réforme la gauche est
arrivée aux deux ans après la gauche est
arrivé au bois elle n'a rien fait pour
évident évidemment revenir sur cette
réforme parce que parce que c'est le bon
sens parce que c'est ce qui se passe
qui va être voté par la droite
un gouvernement de gauche aurait pu
l'apporter cette réforme aucun
gouvernement de droite donc je parle
d'une réforme que je connais bien
puisque c'est celle que j'ai fait j'ai
twitté à ce moment-là et j'ai tweeté
voilà c'est une réforme de gauche et moi
je suis la reine d'Angleterre voilà je
crois que c'est à peu près ce que ça
mérite pourquoi ne verrions-nous pas des
élus RN dans la rue également je pense
que le blocage n'est peut-être pas la
solution idéale dans la mesure et moi je
suis très réticent sur ce sujet parce
que en fait ça pénalise les Français les
plus modestes mais intervenez c'est
votre effort défendez là c'est ça le
Parlement
se taire c'est pas d'avoir le bâillon
retaillot sur la bouche réponse
justement du baillon rotaïo il n'y a pas
de silence que nous ne tomberons pas
dans le piège que vous nous demandez
vous voulez faire de l'obstruction et
nous pas que se passe-t-il avec
Versailles et bien figurez-vous que
cette dame Catherine péga continue de
diriger l'établissement de Versailles
donc alors que son mandat a expiré il y
a un an et demi et Libération nous
explique que c'est une volonté du couple
Macron qui s'affranchit des règles pour
prolonger le mandat donc de Catherine
Pégard aux États-Unis nouvelle sortie de
Donald Trump l'ancien président a
affirmé qu'il était le seul à pouvoir
empêcher je cite une troisième guerre
mondiale
la détention provisoire de pierre
Palm V pour raison médicale décision de
la juge d'instruction en charge du
dossier l'humoriste avait fait un AVC le
25 février il est actuellement
hospitalisé à l'hôpital de Marie de
Lannelongue ou Plessis-Robinson le
parquet de Melun a déjà fait appel
regardez ses habitants qui ont dû écrire
un message de détresse sur la neige
tombée on est donc ici en plein cœur de
la Californie leur village était
totalement coupé du monde et donc pour
prévenir les autorités bien on a trouvé
cette solution heureusement les secours
sont arrivés notamment pour leur
apporter de l'eau et de quoi manger
heureusement pour eux